dans le monde il existe des centaines de
races de poules domestiques parfois elle
compose de tout petits troupeaux présent
seulement dans leur pays d'origine
mais depuis quelques années des
collectionneurs et des amateurs de pools
de races différentes se sont mis à les
multiplier
voici le portrait d'un homme et de sa
passion pour ces volatiles et les
ferrone de yamachiche à ob il élève des
poules de race inhabituel d'importants d
identifier oui ces propos mais je me
rase les uns que vous vivez comme ff et
quand il ya de la demande
oui qu'on va mettre les effets qu'ont
les faits quand on peut les porter ou
les liens venus chercher ici vos clients
sont sains
le canado combler c'est humain comme moi
tu veux avoir une spéciale soit pour la
beauté de la peau ou quelqu'un qui veut
élever dans sa basse cour
on trouve des spécimens de poing
spectaculaires comme l'allemande et
colorer vos rouergue plus étrange la
iame se manie descendante des poules
noir de java en indonésie
la québécoise chantecler
et l'anglais the lights au sexe est
intéressant la politique on doit c'est
une grâce à deux fins en trois temps
pour la charte pour lui encore qui pèse
5 shillings carcasse un coût adulte donc
ces catégories grosse grosse phase de
poules les enfants peuvent l'approcher
oui je passais le maire leur coque et
prague à cette pente au caron plus des
collectionneurs un nouveau marché ton
explosion les éleveurs de poules
urbaines amateurs d'oiseaux de toutes
les couleurs pour demander sa grosse
voix une peau lisse et brillant au dakar
les poules de race pondent des oeufs de
différentes teintes et les gourmets à la
mode en veulent
[Musique]
malgré son apparence surprenante la iame
ses manies est une poule domestique
comme une autre c'est un copain donnait
comme on peut voir les trottoirs lannoy
du vieux noir qu'est-ce à dire la même
chose j'ai pas vu de différence
j'en ai mangés puis je pouvais différent
de l'agglo de poule et puis c'est un bon
poulet mais trop de viande brune c'est
moins qu'on dit que les autres s
affrontaient 150 par année
c'est pas une grosse grosse pondeuses
très bonne couverture maternelle ce
point de variétés d'agressif non plus
cette inévitable l'éleveur à sa poule
chouchou l'accord week c'est un terme
que c'est une de mes préférées
pourquoi sa couleur sa rareté
elle est rare oui frère au canada puis
elle tombe bien wall très bien sa faune
300 euros par anaïs un traceur tarde
toujours comme ça de deux trois couleurs
oui la tête noire et baby anglais je
vous disais noir que noir
eric fehr ont collectionné les poules
bien avant la vague actuelle à 16 ans
j'avais mon auto que j'allais l'ontario
nabi un cadre dans leur lit dans le
monde viennent chercher leur poule ils
se font les plus urbains lors son tour
heureux c'est qu'on lui qui gagnait en
revanche ceux qui veulent quelqu'un il
vient chercher une pole il veut tout le
temps avoir toutes mes autres pôles
pilot l'aï dit l'année prochaine mais
sans période comme so when comme ça ça
finit souvent demain
[Musique]